Good morning, John, I'm apparently at a water
park because it is very hot here.
Also, because my life is amazing and marvelous
and one of the other things that's making
my life amazing and marvelous these days is
that very soon, we will have, for the first
time, non-horribly blurry pictures from Pluto.
New Horizons has been traveling for nine years
- it was launched in 2006.
In addition to containing a bunch of scientific
experiments, spectrographs, cameras, that
kind of thing, it's also carrying the ashes
of Clyde Tombaugh, the guy who discovered
Pluto.
Which is pretty cool, he gets to like actually
go there.
I think there's going to be a conversation
about this in the comments no matter what;
I just gotta say, Pluto's not a planet.
And the reason that Pluto is not a planet
is the same reason why I am so excited about
the New Horizons mission: which is that Pluto
is freakin' weird.
Woah!
The Kuiper belt is a ring of really loosely-packed,
icy, rocky worlds out beyond the orbit of
Neptune, and Pluto is the largest of the Kuiper
belt objects.
They're so far away we've never studied the
Kuiper belt objects, except we kind of have.
Triton is a moon of Neptune that is just a
little bit bigger than Pluto and composed
roughly of the same stuff.
[Splash!]
Failure!
Now, we know quite a bit about Triton, because
once upon a time we actually visited it.
Because Triton orbits Neptune backwards, people
think that it was probably captured from the
Kuiper belt by Neptune as part of this weird
Solar-System-changing event that happened
like 4 billion years ago, in which Neptune
and Uranus switched places, also potentially
causing the destruction of like thousands
of Pluto-sized bodies.
Pluto has 5 moons, uh, they're some of the
weirdest moons in the Solar System and we
didn't even know it had 5 moons until pretty
recently.
Before New Horizons launched we didn't even
know about 2 of them, so now it's headed on
it's way to Pluto and there are new moons
to watch out for, and there may be more moons
we don't even know about, which actually presents
danger.
The New Horizons could crash into one of those
moons, which would end the mission, which
would be very sad.
We wouldn't even know what happened, because
we wouldn't be able to get any data about
it.
Those moons were probably collected on the
Kuiper belt which Pluto spends most of its
time in.
A couple of them have these weird wobbly orbits
that so if you were on the surface of them,
you would never know when the sun was going
to come up.
Sometimes the sun would rise in the east and
then like, set in the north.
New Horizons is now more than 4.5 billion
kilometers away, and to get there it had to
exit Earth's orbit faster than any object
ever has before, spend a bunch of time tailing
Jupiter and have Jupiter like suck it forward
to speed it up even further.
It's going so fast now that of course it can
never slow down, so it's just gonna blast
past Pluto and deeper into the Kuiper belt.
Since transmitting data from 4.5 billion kilometers
away requires a lot of fine-tuning, New Horizons
cannot take pictures and transmit data at
the same time, so as it approaches over the
next week it's going to be taking pictures
like crazy, but it won't be able to send us
any data.
This is because the transmission speeds are
so terribly slow, slower than, like, an early
90s modem, it's going to take months for us
to get all the data that we're gonna get from
this thing, that is going to give us a truly
rich and deep and amazing understanding of
this mostly unexplored world.
I'm very excited.
John, New Horizons will be making its closest
approach on Tuesday, so if you could put a
picture on the video that would be fantastic.
I'm really excited for everybody to see it,
just like you're excited for everybody to
see the Paper Towns movie.
John!
I will see you on Tuesday!
[Bubbles blub blub]
We will of course be covering the New Horizons
mission like crazy on SciShow, and I encourage
you to also check out our new series specifically
designed for elementary school students, Crash
Course Kids.